[Music]
[__]
me
[Music]
pathetic that was better though right
dionya
you'll get there eventually
[Music]
donnie bond will fall they're coming
the sacrifice it wasn't enough
mom
mom dad
dad get to the old stone
it'll protect you
god
[Music]
protect us
yes
uh
ah
[Applause]
mom
i'll take care of your mother get out of
[Applause]
here
here this way
let it go
[Music]
wait
we planted goodly
[Music]
we should have seen this coming there
was never going to be enough blood for
all of us
there is plenty to go around it's just
not what it used to be
this blood drought has escalated
mclaughlin sunk an entire city into the
underworld
the fall of daniban is a brazen act of
war
and more blood sacrifices for the gods
of the underworld means fewer for
us he's going to keep stealing
sacrifices
maybe we should do the same if we start
abducting cities
we're no better than he is we can no
longer consider ourselves above this
conflict
it may be time to use what the only
people left behind
you mean close the gates you must be
joking
no we can't what the old mate did to the
gates
is the reason we wiped them out do you
have a better idea
it could work we closed the five gates
to the underworld
we got them all from earth and the
human's blood for good
ending the blood drought i agree
we finish what they all make started we
close the underworld
for the sake of the balance dipping the
scales in our favor isn't balance
it's not really about balance it's about
our survival
if it is what we all want then i'll
close the gates
no he can't be trusted his twin serves
mcflanta coodley
he's going to starve if anyone is to
imprison my brother down there
it should be me
so be it gets a bottle you are to close
the five gates
figure it out quickly i'll handle it
since you're so attached to them you
should know at the equinox
i will begin the destruction remaking of
the humans
their infighting their wars they've
become petty creatures of violence
their blood is spilled in waste on the
battlefield rather than given to us
their nobility and usefulness has waned
we've remade humanity four times before
did it really help them or us
god repellent obsidian remarkable
ironic that we wiped out the best of our
creations
we can't operate the old make devices
anyway they're all made of this
so let's make a benefit i'll use a human
to close the five gates a pet
before the equinox there's no possible
way a human can not only that
i'll choose the lowest of the low to do
it
even the most pathetic can prove their
worth
hmm i don't trust you a compromise then
you'll use one of my emissaries to guide
the human to ensure there's no trickery
who's your most loyal emissary
yeah he'll do and the stakes
our lives whoever wins gets the blood
sacrifices of the other
i'll take your bet who shall be your
lowest of the low
oh you'll see humanity's champion
is nearly ready
[Music]
gizelle get it together
uh almost ready
[Music]
is it any good it's garbage isn't it
you're an
idiot it's exquisite when did you get
better than mom
let's go get your stuff together
before he sells you instead of your work
[Music]
you really think they'll sell what if we
wait til next week
just sell your stuff today i don't know
if i'm ready
begrudge your destiny as i do mine
amongst the elders
you made this our artisan in training
for those pieces we'll say three one and
a half
it's been a rough harvest a smaller size
then if you're cinching your belt
his skin and bones you wouldn't want the
prodigy to go hungry
uh two we have a deal
gonna be the death of me if the crop fly
doesn't kill me first
she stop your sister i'm aware
pardon me do you have any food to spare
sorry we don't here
did you come all this way from donnybon
i'm so sorry
we heard about oh you're not like the
others
[Music]
you're not maya are you we were born in
tenochtitlan
in mexico territory we left when we were
very young
i hope you and your family will make a
home here as we have
we we may not stay our only goal was to
get as far away from the destruction as
possible
well you're in luck ushmal might as well
be the ends of the earth
gizelle mainly let's go
there's an emergency meeting i have to
attend i need you to be there in case i
fall asleep
can you handle taking this home uh i've
got it
the ends of the earth honestly you must
be the rudest boy nushmah
that poor woman it's the truth you did
the right thing
you make it sound like i never do you
might actually be growing up
[Music]
so you help those foreigners back there
why do you care
[Music]
war from all over cities invaded not the
level of donovan
not yet there have been monsters for as
long as we can remember
but it's getting worse they sunk an
entire city
whatever the gods are quarreling over
this is a massive upturn
we must perform a sacrifice
[Music]
where have you been you got me worried
what on earth
the boys from the marketplace they said
what are you talking about
what happened they beat me up they said
something about a
sacrifice is that true what if something
happens to you
listen you have a master who's taken
care of you for most of your life
and even if he was gone nohosh lives in
austin you could go live with him
but i am always going to be with you
anything broken no
come here ow sorry
we both had a big day and i am
starving come help you want to make
dinner
[Music]
how's your face better uh
i had a nice night i'm glad
that means a lot to me
it's time
[Music]
what's going on
you have two tanoshka servants in your
employ do you not
what about them not both
the boy
[Music]
no no not iselle he's my baby brother
i'll be the sacrifice i'll take his
place
sacrifice giving willingly is the most
noble
swear to me you'll care for him natalie
don't do this swear to me
[Music]
i swear what are you doing now
no don't leave me iselle
be brave
her sacrifice might save us all she
chose to take your place
[Music]
uh
i need help
don't let them take her don't let them
take her from me oh
it's bloody want right it's just blood
it's just blood
iselle stop i'm sorry zell you can't
let go of me he's there stop they've got
nelly
stop him
let me go
i love you iselle it's okay
[Music]
may this sacrifice we're freely giving
your honor appease you
and protect us
now we might stand a chance
[Music]
so
this is humanity's champion
[Music]
lord
see
[Music]
you